-This film is shot
abroad in London, Morocco.
I imagine you were away from
home for a long time.
-Yeah, that was,
what was it like,
three months or so in total.
It was definitely the longest
that I've ever been
away from home.
So, I definitely found myself
getting homesick
from time to time.
And that honestly,
I feel like was
one of the toughest things about
the project, actually.
Especially being in London,
where it's like --
I don't know.
London to me felt like
an alternate dimension,
like in the "Spider-verse"
or something where it's like,
most things are the same,
but there's just things that are
just slightly different enough
to make you
a little uncomfortable.
Like, "Wait, where am I?"
-You know, one of the other
things that I talked about
last night with Charlize,
was the fact this is a film
that had a female director,
female producers,
obviously two female stars.
Was that a fun environment
to be part of?
-Yeah, definitely.
And I mean, just cool to be
in an environment where
so many women were leading.
And now to see --
I mean, it's crazy, you know,
that it's still such a topic
of conversation,
like as if though women aren't
leading every day,
women aren't phenomenal
directors and action heroes
every single day.
So, I'm hoping this will,
I don't know,
give us a good push in the
direction of it becoming
more of the norm
as it should be.
-There was obviously no premiere
for this film.
Did you watch it
with your family
right as it came live
on Netflix?
-I did. I did.
Which was awesome.
You know, as much as I love
a big premiere moment,
it did make this, you know,
feel that much more special
because, I mean, it's no secret,
this is a huge milestone
for my career.
And to be able to celebrate
that,
you know, with the people
who have been
a part of this journey with me
from the very beginning,
since I was 7 years old
and said,
"Hey, I want to act,"
it actually made it, you know,
that much more special.
-And tell me, how is your mom
with the violence
in the film?
Because you know, there's --
and you particularly, you know,
you take it pretty badly
a few times.
-Yeah.
She was fine.
It honestly was my dad.
Like, I mean, I guess spoiler.
Whatever, it's on Netflix.
It's all good,
but so my first death --
my mom, she took it, you know,
a little uncomfortable.
But my dad, I had to like go
up to him and like rub him
on his back like, "Hey, dad.
[ Laughter ]
I'm okay."
Just kind of like silently
sniffling.
But, yeah.
-I imagine violence
won't be an issue
in another film of yours that,
maybe language will be an issue
for your parents, but I'm very
excited about the fact
that you play
Eddie Murphy's daughter
in the "Coming to America"
sequel
that will be
coming out soon.
How was that?
I mean,
I can't tell you how
jealous I am of the fact
that you got to be on a set
with Eddie Murphy
and Wesley Snipes and Arsenio.
So tell me what it was like.
-Man, it was -- I mean,
it was incredible.
I mean, I was surrounded by
people who are truly
masters of their craft.
And just being able to sit back,
and watch, and absorb
and learn from that,
I mean, I'm very grateful,
you know, that this early
in my career, I get this type
of exposure to, you know,
these really -- I mean,
masters at their craft.
And actually, I do kick a --
I do kick a little ass
in "Coming to America."
I will just say that.
-Oh, good to know!
Good to know! A little --
another spoiler alert.
[ Laughter ]
-...just slide that in there.
-Uh-oh.
I mean, at this point,
it would be a waste
of your talents
to not let you kick a little ass
in a movie.
Just a little bit if somebody
gets out of line.
-Yeah.
-Is it -- Was it --
I mean, obviously there's
still work to do
when you're on a movie set,
but was the atmosphere
celebratory that
everybody was back together
making this beloved movie again?
-Very much so.
Very, very much so.
So it was great to be in that
energy as well.
And I mean, it's such a classic,
and these are all people
that love that first film,
love working together.
And so, you know,
just to be able to
witness kind of this
family reunion of sorts
and then to be invited to be
a part of that family --
I mean, yeah, it's special.
It's so special.
-How old do you think you were
when you saw
the first "Coming to America?"
-Ooh, I would have been way
younger than I should have been
to be watching.
[ Laughter ]
-I feel like a lot of
people saw that movie
when they were too young.
-Probably somewhere between
like 8 and 10,
because it's my eldest brother's
favorite movie.
So, the first time I would
have watched it
would have been with him,
and, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
That's the price
of older siblings.
You sometimes see stuff
a little too early.
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, thanks so much
for being here.
Congrats on the film.
Such a delight to speak
with you and to meet you.
-Thank you.
Same to you, Seth.